oh Marvel
what did you do now
[Music]
so
Marvel Comics and to be clear I am
talking specifically about the comics
not the MCU uh in this video although
the MCU is going to factor into this
somewhat will get there when we get to
there
but uh Marvel Comics has really stepped
in it and I would say they may have
stepped in it about as badly as they
ever have since I would say the last
time they stepped in it this bad was
Hydra cap in that whole thing although
um admittedly part of the reason that
was such a mess was because Marvel was
super insist no for real this is what
we're actually doing and instead of just
you know either saying nothing or
running up to the fact of what everybody
already guessed this is some weird
altered history and it's not actually
cap
but we're not going to go off on that
whole thing it was a not great idea not
exceptionally well executed some decent
moments but whatever no no this time
they've decided to kill off
Kamala Khan now at my time of speaking
we don't have full context for this yet
because the issue in which it happens
which will be amazing Spider-Man number
26 and like side tangent real quick can
Marvel can you stop restarting the
numbering you know I've got comic books
from the 90s packed away in a long box
that include Spider-Man issue number 300
and now we're on Amazing Spider-Man
issue number 26.
stop anyways that issue is not actually
out yet however the fact that Kamala
Khan is going to die has leaked and
Marvel has definitely not denied that
that happens in fact they've so the
degree that they've revealed anything
they've revealed that the Fallout is
going to be uh covered in you know its
own kind of big thing and they're
bringing back to you Willow Wilson who
effectively created the character and
wrote her for the majority of her
Mainline comic series is going to write
that now that it's known they're
starting to milk it
but at time of recording they also
haven't really said much about the
justifications for why they may or may
not think this is a good idea
and people are ticked
people are ticked for a number of
reasons
the first is obviously Kamala Khan
is a very beloved character now is she
at the height of her popularity no not
really her solo book got canceled in
2021 after a pretty successful run but
she's definitely one of their most
successful characters that they have
introduced in the last
10 15 years she's done really well she's
popular people like her again the sales
numbers aren't always there but that
does not mean that people dislike her it
can be tough to judge the popularity of
a character by sales numbers alone that
just means that their book isn't signed
but that doesn't mean people want them
gone so never assume that because
somebody's book was canceled that makes
the character disposable a lot of these
characters have really devoted fan bases
and even the people who maybe never
bought her individual books or the
graphic novel compilations of which I
own several even they probably largely
have a positive feeling towards her I
mean there are some people who have
never liked her for
let's just say it really nonsense
reasons but uh I acknowledge those
people exist I do not address them or
their arguments because it's all
nonsense but anyways
so Kamala Khan dying there's the act in
and of itself killing a major and
beloved character is always a risky
thing for any comic book Marvel or DC to
even attempt to do because if you don't
do it right you're gonna tick a lot of
people off and even if you do it right
you're still gonna take a chunk of
people off it's just a question of
whether you take off the majority or not
and yeah people are not happy about this
and not only because of the simple fact
that she is dying I mentioned we don't
Know full context as to you know why it
happens how it happens you know is it a
noble sacrifice is it you know what what
is it exactly won't that make a
difference no not really because the
main reason people are ticked off is
because she's dying as a side character
in somebody else's book you need to
understand the importance and the impact
of Kamala Beyond just the fact that
people like her
she is one of only a handful at this
point really notable teenage heroes in
Marvel Marvel characters at this point
skew older I mean a lot of them are
technically in their 20s but like
they're written as if they're in their
30s and they generally kind of read that
way we've got Miles Morales we had
Kamala Khan and there's like a bunch of
side ones but there aren't that many
prominent teenage characters so that's
one thing secondly
she's a Muslim character now I see some
people misconstrue that she is either
the only or was the first Muslim
superhero she's not there's actually a
number of others there's Josiah X
there's dust there's Dr Fazio Hussain
who is actually pretty dang cool and she
wields freaking Excalibur but the thing
is none of those people have had their
own Main Line book she has so she has
undeniably the most prominent Muslim
character in the Marvel Comics Canon and
as I said the only one who's been a
title character for a regular book so
there's that there's how few Pakistani
or Pakistani American characters there
are not a lot of those either
so
they took a beloved character
who is non-white
has an immigrant family
has a minority religion
and they kill her off
not even in her own book and when I say
she's been a minor supporting character
in Spider-Man lately I mean that yes
she's been popping up but out of the
last 25 issues of The Amazing Spider-Man
she's appeared in five
she's not in there as an equal partner
she hasn't been like integrated as a
major ongoing subplot she's a thing
that's popped up here and there she's
had her own subplot kind of but she's
not a major Focus
you couldn't say she was a major
supporting character on the scale of
well I would say Mary Jane I don't even
know are they dating now no he's dating
black cat now I can't keep track of what
they're doing with Peter's love life
it's a mess regardless she doesn't rise
to the status of even major supporting
characters she is a minor recurring
character in this
and I've talked before about how when
you place minority characters in minor
supporting roles like this
they tend to be treated as more
disposable not necessarily because of
their race religion or other minority
status but because
minor characters minor Side characters
are inherently more disposable so when
that's where you put
your representative characters for
minorities guess what a lot of minority
characters die except that you know why
was she even relegated to this in the
first place which of course brings us to
the question
why would they do this on its first
impression it makes no sense like Ms
Marvel has premiered on Disney plus
she's gonna be in a movie soon why would
they kill her in the comics what sense
does that make
well not a lot unless you know the
context of what's been going on in the
comics and also some of the things that
Marvel has done with the comics in the
wake of the MCU so the first thing is
you need to understand there has been a
general trend
for the Marvel Comics to
crowbar in some reasons to bring the
comics version of their characters more
in line with the MCU because the MCU
characters they get adapted they get
changed for one reason or another you
know changes to backstory changes to
power set changes to the iconography and
the outfit or what have you and it is
not uncommon for those changes to be
integrated in some cases even retconned
into the original Comics so that the
comic characters
seem more like their uh their movie
counterparts
which I'll just say up front I think
that's a really stupid idea
I do I just think that's a terrible idea
I'm not going to say it's never a great
idea like I'll give you an example where
it makes a lot of sense negasonic
teenage Warhead from Deadpool that was a
side character who literally meant
nothing and was picked at random simply
because the name was so cool for the
Deadpool movie and they did completely
their own thing and she was awesome and
that was a meaningless character in the
comic so yeah sure make that change
that's fine but when changes are
happening to beloved characters and
they're doing well in the movies and you
go well let's change the comics to be
more like that well
I know the theory is people will be more
likely to pick up the comics if they're
in line with the movies except that
you know a decade plus of the comic
sales failing to get much of a boost off
the back of the movies shows that that's
not true that doesn't happen I would
argue it gives you less of a reason to
read the comics because it's not like oh
what's different what what can I find
what's the deeper things what what are
the things that they change will I find
this more interesting oh oh no it's it's
just the same thing now it used to be
different but it's not anymore oh okay
and then of course you tick off the
longtime readers who are the reason
these characters are popular enough to
be put in the movies in the first place
like this is stupid I understand why
they started doing it it hasn't worked
and I wish they would stop
but that has been going on for a long
time
whether it has been adjusting characters
costumes to be more in line adjusting
their powers heck this even goes back
older than the MCU when Spider-Man 3
came out the Sam Raimi Spider-Man 3 they
contrived a reason to have Peter in a
black costume in the comics so they've
been doing this for ages and it's never
really worked
they still keep doing it anyway it's
like they don't know how to stop
so
why did I bring all that up
am I suggesting that they are going to
be killing Kamala Khan in the Marvels
and that's why they're going to kill her
in the comics no that's not what I'm
suggesting
but
killing her in the comics is heavily
speculated to be a mechanism by which to
bring her more in line with the
uh MCU version because there's a couple
of key differences with the MCU version
well there's basically two there's two
big ones
one has to do with her power set and the
other has to do with the source of her
powers
now the powerset want to set aside I'll
mention it again real quickly uh towards
the back end but we're going to focus on
where her powers come from
because the MCU
in the I believe was the very last
episode of the Ms Marvel TV show
hinted at the idea of mutation Kamala if
there's something different
in your genes like a mutation
the idea that she is a mutant which
would be a way to start introducing
mutants and then eventually the X-Men
and in and of itself for the MCU that's
fine
that's fine like the specifics of where
her powers came from
I'm not gonna say it had no meaning I'll
talk a little bit more about what it was
in the comics and it did tie her to
certain characters that made for some
interesting things but by and large most
issues the exact origin of her of her
powers didn't matter in the comics she
was just gonna have her adventures do
her slightly fan girly Thing be awkward
and adorable and wonderful it didn't
really matter exactly where her powers
came from so I didn't really have a
problem with them changing into mutation
I did think that the way they introduced
it with just this this character going
it's like a mutation and they do a
little lick of the 90s uh X-Men cartoon
theme like like a mutation
[Music]
that I didn't really love but that had
to do with execution not concept
in the comics she's not a mutant she's
an inhuman
now depending on how good your memory is
you may recall that the Inhumans was a
very failed
uh attempt at a TV show that and this
was like prior to Disney plus so they
pretend it didn't happen anymore but
this whole thing gets really convoluted
really quick
the whole mutants and Inhumans thing is
very inter meshed for dumb reasons
so for a long time Fox before Disney
bought it was a separate entity held the
adaptation rights for film and also for
TV for X-Men characters and any related
mutant characters now there were some
characters who kind of ended up in a
weird middle ground and they got shared
custody over like Quicksilver and uh and
Scarlet Witch but for the most part Fox
had the mutants and the X-Men
now Ike Pearl mutter
who at the time was heading up Marvel
just as a whole
he really hated the idea
that anything that they did in the
comics might somehow generate interest
in the movies because he hated that fox
had the rights to these movies
and so the importance of mutants and
actually the sheer population of mutants
was continually being downplayed for a
chunk of time they were being killed off
left and right a bunch of mutants got
de-powered and then
there was the whole thing they did with
the Inhumans so the Inhumans super
simplified are a um race of beings they
live on the moon they were tinkered with
um sort of genetically and they uh exist
kind of in parallel to humanity and the
way that they manifest powers and their
powers can be just about anything but
the way they manifest Powers is it gets
unlocked by exposure to a thing called
terrigen mist
so what Pearl mutter had them do in an
effort to minimize anything that he
perceived as being some kind of free
publicity for X-Men related stuff that
fox was doing minimized the X-Men and
went big on the Inhumans and that
included something called The terrigen
Mist bomb which basically sent tarajin
Mist across the entire planet and normal
people it does not affect them but
anyone with the correct specific inhuman
Gene would suddenly develop powers and
that is where Kamala Khan got her powers
and again this was an effort to
basically just still have a bunch of
people with random weird wild powers
that you don't have to explain the
origin for but have that not be mutants
anymore because that's what mutants had
become they were a catch-all for we want
somebody with a power and we don't have
to come up with an origin it's a mutant
they have this as a mutation cool
they've replaced that within humans
basically and so Kamala Khan her powers
are because she's an inhuman she was
exposed to terrorism Mist she developed
her stretchy and beginning Powers but
not only have the Inhumans been sort of
dialed back in the comics their TV show
failed and the MCU is teeing up
bringing in mutants
so what the suspicion is
is that killing Kamala Khan in the
comics is going to facilitate their
having her essentially be reborn as a
mutant I don't have the full details on
exactly how this works but for some
reason right now and honestly this may
have been done specifically for the
purposes of accomplishing what they're
doing with Kamala it wouldn't shock me
at the very least it's a big bonus for
them if it wasn't done for this purpose
but effect right now mutants are
actually immortal if they die they get
reborn on this island I think it's
krakowa
there's a there is an island where
mutants if they die they get reborn on
so while it is not currently confirmed
the big speculation is that Kamala Khan
is going to die and then be reborn and
that will be their way of signaling
she's not actually an inhuman she's a
mutant which would bring it more in line
with what they're going to do with the
MCU so if this is true and I tend to
suspect it is
what's the problem she's just going to
come back anyway
the problem is disrespect
the problem is that you treat a beloved
minority character
you treat her life
as being less important or worth
throwing away even briefly
simply for the purposes of this
convoluted method to alter her origin
because of a TV show and a movie
it shows an extreme amount of disrespect
for her as a character that they would
yank her about in all these directions
and do all this convoluted stuff
just to be slightly more in line with
the MCU
is that how little you think of her
of her history
of all the time that she spent with the
Inhumans of the relationships she's
built of her amazing time with lockjaw
which is some of the best freaking stuff
that Marvel has done in about a decade
does that all mean so little
that you want to do this convoluted
thing that involves killing her
just so that you can have her be a
mutant instead
it just makes it really feel like the
people at Marvel don't understand why
people like her
people don't care if she's a mutant
they care if she continues to have the
wonderful amazing personality and
terrific support and cash she's always
had
and I've said I'd mention her powers
real quick and I am going to mention in
this effect I um
I think that the full cynicism will be
on display if
in addition to doing this
um and having her be reborn as a mutant
if they also use that as an opportunity
to alter her powers so they work more
like they do in the MCU too because in
the MCU she basically has light
construction powers and she does use
them in a create a giant arm and shift
this kind of thing but in the comic she
just has straight up stretching powers
and that was actually kind of key
because her powers when she uses them it
looks weird it's off-putting it's gangly
it's awkward because she's an awkward
gangly teenager it's thematic and now
it's just light constructs and I would
not be shocked but I would be
disappointed
if they also take this whole thing and
bring her back and use it as an
opportunity to make her powers look more
like they do in the MCU as well
the thing about this kind of move
is it always signals that the editors
I'm not going to necessarily say the
creators because oftentimes the writers
are working under editorial mandate and
while they're usually
um very reticent to ever say they were
forced to do this stuff if they want to
keep working in the industry it's in
their best interest not to say that if
that is the case so I'm not necessarily
going to blame the on the ground level
writers but I am going to blame the
editors
I'm gonna blame the editorial staff
who are treating this character as just
a pawn to be moved around until she is
more in line with the more popular
version
it shows such a disregard
for the history for the love for the
fandom for the fact that there's nothing
wrong with her being her own thing in
the comics that is not exactly like the
movies
it's just a slap in the face
even if the story is good
even if they come up with a really
beautiful
death I know that's an awkward phrase to
say but like narratively you can do
tragedy really well even if it's a
beautiful death it still shows a
disregard and a disrespectful or that
they would do this to her at all much
less when she is a minor supporting
player in somebody else's book
I think people are right to be ticked
off about this
she's not only a beloved character she's
an important character she's a unique
character and not just for the diversity
quota but because she brings an energy
that a lot of Marvel doesn't have in the
MCU are out of it
so yeah
this is nonsense
and I don't like it
what are your thoughts on this do you
think there's another reason why they're
gonna kill Kamala Khan do you think it
might actually be a good idea
I I don't on either front but whatever
your thoughts might be drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
patreon pays the bills enables me to do
this as my living even if you can't
assist me that way like share subscribe
those also help me out
don't worry too much about it though
whether you know Kamala whether you're a
fan of hers from the MCU from the comics
or you've never heard of her before
what I really want you to remember
is you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
bernabelax the poodle Robin Powell Tracy
scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL Taylor
David Hall Shayla Gourley and Rosalind
Bennett thanks for your support you can
get your name in the credits too if you
feel like hearing me possibly struggle
with it for several times before getting
it right
[Music]
no no